mom was losing her short-term memory but
was better recalling her younger years
I'd ask and she would tell me stories
I listened and I was her audience
I got ideas I wrote them down and I
sketched them out
I showed her what to do by acting out
the scenarios myself
we would then stage them
so she posed
and I learned more about photography
mom loved the process the acting he felt
worthy again she felt wanted and needed
with any Alzheimer's dementia there's
a certain amount of frustration and
sadness for everyone involved but to
balance off all the difficulties we
played that was Mom's happy place
and I needed her to be there too